encore deux minutes jour a simplement
appelé véronique colucci
la femme de coluche et aldo en finesse
le lancet
enfin
très bien
[Applaudissements]
mais je j'ai eu l'occasion comme toi
d'ailleurs de participer dimanche ses
très vives à cette fête en fait parce
que c'était une fête du coeur qu'avec
avait lieu sur sur tf1 et on avait et
puis j'avais j'avais envie de trouver
cette idée là tout le monde donnait des
idées on va faire ça à faire ça et je
vous en avais parlé hier vous le public
est là elle et puis les gens qui sont
venus et qui n'étaient pas là hier
et puis vous avez tous marché puisqu'il
ya dans cette boîte l'équivalent de
mille repas ils ont par exactement voilà
c'est la première promesse contenue
c'est formidable ce soit vous qui
étaient là je suis vraiment content que
vous soyez tous merci
mais quelle est cette affaire
[Applaudissements]
parce que qu'est-ce que vous aviez un
espoir avant dimanche c'est ce que ces
espoirs ont été réalisées
quotidiennement on est en train de voir
le résultat de l'émission de dimanche
chaque jour il sa porte à nouveau chèque
en fin dé nous donne des nouveaux repas
et c'est formidable c'est formidable
votre téléphone vous comptez pouvoir
faire combien de combien de repas à cet
hiver il faudrait qu'on fasse ce 14
millions d'euros pour les trois mois
d'hiver c'est à dire faire ça ça coûte
1000 repas par jour et je vais écouter
tout ce que je vous souhaite d'abord ce
que je vais vous dire sur cette boîte et
les ponts rousset pour les restaurants
du coeur j'essai très lourd fait le
temps d'envoyer on va la faire
voilà vous l'apprenez je vous remercie
d'être venus j'espère que cette ce petit
quelque chose va pouvoir vous donner un
coup de main si beaucoup et surtout
donner un coup de main aux mille
personnes qui sont qui sont dehors et
qui vont avoir très faim j'aurais conrad
qu'on appelle le compte chèque postal je
sais pas si on va le voir apparaître sur
l'écran
si on le voit pas le voilà si vous
voulez envoyer de l'argent par chèque
baldo allez-y il faut libérer le chèque
au crédit agricole
les restaurants du coeur il faut
l'envoyer crédit agricole le restaurant
du coeur ça c'est l'ordre les
restaurants du coeur c'est l'ordre du
chèque exactement vrai il adressé 75515
paris cedex 15
voilà en espérant que tout ceci continue
comme comme comme c'est parti mon claude
on va pas revenir là dessus je crois que
c'est vrai que tout a été dit qu'il faut
maintenant que tout le monde agisse
exactement ce que disait hier michel a
écrit de la main sur une affiche on
compte sur vous je vois que son petit et
son petit conseil a été suivi il faut
qu'il le soit encore voilà alors
effectivement comme vient de le dire on
compte sur vous et les restaurants du
coeur compte sur vous merci à tous
d'avoir participé à sa merci et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]